j'essaierai soir
l'intéressé a eu dans la balance
astrid veillon paco rabanne vous
connaissez déjà dire que le livre
d'elisabeth tessier est sorti trois mois
avant le mien un accord avant lui le
porte-parole qui commence ainsi le 15
avril cédait 3 - 0 3% il a demandé
daniel malingue
on a eu le dessus depuis deux semaines
nous ne sommes jamais que le le monde
là encore le cannabis avait pas de
caméra mois et ben moi je pense qu'il a
envoyée en la tenant il en sortira le
12 août la barre
vous connaissiez pas ses yeux
elizabeth teissier qui était mannequin
travail et travaille dans les assurances
de c'est un canonnier jeu
hier j'ai jamais été votée à cannes
j'ai fait des photos pour vous dans une
sous dialyse magnifique robe métallique
la délégation est arrivée cet hiver
paco comme un couturier absolument
génial génial on en a parlé à tous
avec une échéance plus dire après ce
que j'ai entendu de se clore le grenelle
à paris elle tente alors
apa - harare on n'a même pas eu le
temps
avalos 31 ans a parlé tout à l'heure
ce qu'il faut dire c'est donc
effectivement de quoi encore
vous avez 100%
ce n'était pas le cas bref
vous avez été mannequin vedette
anglais
vous avez layana karembeu est très
connue parce que la fin est très
célèbre et dans le guinness book des
records parce qu'elle a des gens qui
mesure 1 mètre vingt de katibougou
jambes de rêve annette 15
pour une taille d'un mètre en faire
baisser aussi assez tôt c'était parce
qu'il est meilleur que moi sans que
personne le 6 janvier pour une durée de
2 4 hectares
vous avez marcq
a comme ça me parle je savais pas mais
vous voulez ainsi ont été si nombreux
à paris et non
voici deux ans plus tard
dallas
alors vous êtes directeur de chez
chanel parce que c'est une photo
françois vignola qui valait 69 3 94%
sabine fischer a beaucoup énervé % la
maison chanel on attend qu'elle était
en train de créer et à leur pack
audois comprend de cinq mois avant que
le sort des rangs d'adissan 15000 francs
au canton même accepté de me citer des
noms voilà maintenant qu'il faut dire
ça vous avez des comédiennes
ou alors vous râlez à chaque fois
qu'on vous parle du film que vous êtes
171 eden hazard a très peu de
frustration
pour moi j'ai vu le film séraphine
barnier main en attente au large du port
je pense pas non je vous demandais alors
publiquement
quand on vous voit dans le film cette
magnifique
et je ne vois pas quel problème il ya
aussi on ne fait pas du tout les gestes
enchanté un procès je vienne gagné
d'ailleurs contre à peine perdue il
faut bien dire que ce qui a été
engagé à publier les photos c'est pas
pareil
oui oui c'est le film le dit lui même
si le temps et la ferrari l'intellectuel
du cinéma pendant la feria et déjà
qu'elle était une action d'envergure
jean paul ii
c'est gentil
dans le nord le problème le problème
c'est que ce livre d'or de ce film
frustration est sorti en fin de match
était palpable érotique et pas de
pornographie voilà après l'avoir bien
sorti à la même époque un beau cadeau
qui s'appelle sous le signe de
mitterrand within parce que c'est vrai
que j'ai été très proche où l'on
avait écrit dans ce livre je soussigné
miki ando françois-mitterrand qui
d'ailleurs voulez à un moment recréée
pour vous une chaire % et d'astrologie
a la sorbonne quand je ne pense pas
qu'ils vivent s'agisse que l'anonymat
est une paire d'enceintes un contact
mais il n'y avait pas ce pouvoir là
vous savez pour le moins
d'universitaires parfois être loi pour
les catégories à levallois-perret
séjour en règle
alors pour rester un petit moment sur
françois mitterrand
l'euro n'a pas voulu les rencontrer vous
aider vous ressemblez à bagard nerfs
oui oui
anne-krystel mois de l'année retrouvez
nous a laissé neuf mois comme c'est un
vrai séducteur mitterrand parce que
vous avez c'est neuf mois sans sans vous
rappeler une sélection qui vous a
laissé mariner pendant neuf mois quand
même plus que les autres at-il assuré
qu'est-ce que vous croyez que
les lauréats seront primés
est-ce que vous croyez qu'il en était
aussi intéressé s'il n'avait pas été
aussi jolie
peut-être que ça a joué un rôle dans
la valse crise ou au secondaire
% de même mais après pas du tout se
passait vraiment très
c'était très très c'était très
technique en fait nous ne nous rendons
était enrhumé par ce qui m'attend
il est très fréquemment demandé ce
que à quoi se demander quelles sont ses
amis et ses ennemis comme si les
écoutes téléphonie telus suffisait
pas
ils voulaient en savoir plus quoi parle
bien entendu du cancer sur la fin c'est
pour cela qu'anwar est vrai qu'en ces
rassemblements
ce soir on va dire quand même avant de
commencer à parler beaucoup de
rencontrer sur les enfants et les
parents pourraient voter parce que vous
avez prévu parce que mine de rien c'est
prévu le changement à l'aise
la chute du communisme
dans re scor 83 ans fédéraux scorpion
ça c'est la prévision ne poursuit plus
fier parce que c'est ça chacun ce qui
semble gêner jamais je vais adorer
arsène son receveur 83 matchs dans la
danse
vous prévoyez des changements à l'aise
d'amran scott 87 h 40 vous prévoyez le
krach boursier
dans vos étoiles en 2000 vous prévoyez
la guerre du golfe
dans rance que 86 pages 36 vous
prévoyez tchernobyl
dans télé 7 jours vous prévoyez la
chute du mur de berlin il est même
prévu de divorce
cinq ans après
alors certaines platines et j'en
parlerai pas
à la baguette
pour laisser s'établir à dire quand
même parce que c'est un malade qui veut
être heureux oui ça c'est sûr
sont quelques prévisions se réalisent
et leur présente un design qui a fermé
dans les années à venir le prochain
président de france télévision paul
george washington a prêté de la
voyante dans un réclamer sur les ailes
à l'audience il a mit alors à une
galerie d'art
oui
alors le passage de tous les dangers
dans le ciel robert laffont en banque
le complice michel grossiord de l'afp ou
encore notre milieu paco rabanne dit que
c'est là
la station spatiale mir la station russe
disant
qui va s'écraser limites parce que il
est dans notre dernier souhaite la paix
nourrir la bête quasi-nul terres
inhabitées et bien s'avérer payante
selon lui
elisa dette grecque si elle parle de la
sonde cassini verrons alors ce que je
vais arriver ce moment-là ce que j'ai
expliqué le comité des droits de
l'homme et il faut que ce soit clair
pour tout le monde vous c'est votre
boulot mais pour les gens c'est pas
toujours très clair quand vous parlez
de la station orbitale
horus meilleure façon de trouver des
gens qui doit tomber
sur paris élizabeth teissier elle parle
effectivement de la cendre cassini
l'idéaliste qui était envoyé sur
saturne par les américains pour une
arrivée en 2004 qui contient une pile
nucléaire de 33 kilos de dioxide
plutonium radioactifs et qui va frôler
la terre à 1170 km le pont rose août
1999 d'année à savoir il faut dire que
dire que cette cette sonde qui est parti
en octobre 97
% et qui doit revenir la ctt et comme
par hasard on s'approche de
l'atmosphère terrestre
qui va donc sur l'approché commune et
dire très très près puisque ça c'est
un chemin puisqu'elle arrive à 68 km et
une vitesse de 60 unités de mettre à
l'heure qu'il est la vitesse une vitesse
météorique et elle va donc arriver à
1191 kilomètres de la terre ce qui est
très peu dangereux
et ils pourront aussi viril manoeuvre
très important très délicate
d'accélération pour partir vers sature
un nouvel arrivant en 2004 à l'heure de
la messe tridentine les lieux ce qui m'a
fait chier d'appariement alors les
syndicats manama mais on essaie de la
ville
car ceux qui mais le rappeler si vous
voulez
c'est le timing
cette accélération cette manoeuvre
doit avoir lieu comme par hasard j'ai
appris par pur hasard parce que le
frère moniteur allemands aient été
arrêtés la nasa app travail du canada
et quand il a vu les prévisions en
allemagne il allie la wilaya d'illizi
aphibio climat téléphoner il me dit
mais vous savez que il y avait 700
continent n'aurait jamais su
aisne
ce qui m'a interpellé justement on sait
que cette année nous avons entre le 11
et le 18 au matin
jossart et la maintenance ça se fait
une pétition en appel au peuple en
disant pour cent et moi-même j'ai un
site sur internet et jeudi je je me suis
procuré le site de la nasa en disant
aux gens
essayez de demander que cette manoeuvre
ne soit pas faite ap ap entre le 13
juillet et le 8 septembre
parce que c'est c'est une période
allant de l homme notamment pour les
enfants pendant les vacances scolaires
mon frère lors d'un séjour à
sécheval adam alors j'espère que
certains y compris la mienne et une
seule étoile compagnon alain joyandet
l'année dernière attendez attendez
clients au détriment des agréments
demandés y avait bien une période
troublée clairement
une période troublée voilà donc de
retour du 11 août
effectivement pour paco rabanne c'est la
station orbitale mir de retrouver son
amour et isabelle tessier sarrebourg et
peut-être évidemment cdc détenait un
stock de lesquin - paris afin d'y être
nous voulons
on n'en est pas là mais alors comment
elles réagissent mal après le
frontispice de l'édition originale
nostradamus
qui montre où la décapitation d'un roi
et en bas une vie qui brûle très bien
jean-marc lalonde justement en avalant
une peine allant jusqu'à un an cela il
faut avancer et vous verrez si
n'écoutez ce soit dans cette affaire je
vous dis pas que c'est une vieille
histoire
je voudrais juste dire que
nostradamus on lui fait dire tout prix
le contraire gratuit les trente mille
ouvrages qui exigeaient à éteindre la
seule tva qui ont été faites sur lui
écrit sur lui école iliad qui m'ait
dit lui-même qu'il ne serait pas
compris avant l'an 2000 cinq ans sera
versé de l'argent à la banque non
c'est pas ça c'est que tout démarre
deux ans comptait pour l'instant ne sont
pas fiancés judiciaire